we're joined now by the labor MP and
Shadow Health secretary Wes streeting
thank you very much for being with us
where do you think we are with all this
this evening
well the cans being kicked to the end of
the road and conservative MPS now need
to make a choice about whether they are
going to give their support to Boris
Johnson either vocal support or their
complicity through their silence to keep
in office someone who has now been
proven to have broken the law to have
lied to the country and to presided over
a culture in number 10 where they
genuinely thought it was one rule for
them one rule for anyone else to the
extent that even when challenged by
their own security and cleaning staff
the cleaners who were having to wipe the
walls of number 10 because of the red
wine stains we see reported in the
sugary report treated with contempt by
people who thought the rules did not
apply to them that's not someone that I
think is fit to run the country and I
think the voters have made the same
conclusion they will now judge
conservative MPS just as harshly if they
stick by a prime minister who is clearly
so unfit for the office he holds was
there enough in the report that
conclusively you know proved that when
it when it came to Boris Johnson
personally that the he was culpable I
mean what more proof do people want I
mean he denied these events even took
place and now we find out that he's
there and the photographs are there it's
clear for everyone to see he's tried to
take the country for fools he's lied to
Parliament that in itself is a
resignation offense and the reason why
this Matters by the way is that if you
allow someone who holds such important
office and holds the trust of the
country in that office and they abuse
that trust and they lie and you let them
get away with it you open that iconic
black door of number 10 so the kinds of
corruption we're not used to seeing in
this country but are used to seeing in
other countries around the world and I
think we all deserve better and so long
as Boris Johnson remains in office he's
not focused on the issues that matter to
people like the cost of living crisis or
how we rebuild our public services in
the aftermath of covert 19. he's focused
on his own Survival and I think that
it's unconscionable actually for
conservative MPS to keep him where he is
but are you worried about what Durham
Police may decide in relation to your
own leader
no I'm not actually I see no evidence to
suggest they will draw any different
conclusion than they did last time but
there is the contrast By the way between
the character and lack of Integrity of
of Boris Johnson versus Kier stammer who
has been really clear that if he is
fined by Durham Police he will resign
well Boris Johnson has been fined has
been proven to have lied has broken the
laws and his own MPS are keeping him in
place but Boris Johnson was making the
point that KIA Stamo was calling for his
resignation at the beginning of the
investigation well I mean Kia stammer is
being investigated now well kirst armor
was calling for Boris Johnson to resign
because it was already clear that he had
lied to the House of Commons and that is
in itself a resignation offense and no
amount of deflection distraction
obfuscation is going to let Boris
Johnson Off The Hook because around
three quarters of people in this country
believe that Boris Johnson knowingly
lied to Parliament and I agree with them
a clear majority of people in this
country believe that Boris Johnson
should resign and I agree with them too
Boris Johnson voters will have to do
that themselves exactly exactly it comes
down to a conservative MPS
yeah it does and look I'll be honest
there are people that I see in the
conservative party who I previously
believed to whatever our disagreements
to be people of Integrity
um and courage who have been utterly
spineless and supine in the face of a
prime minister who has made them look
like fools every cabinet minister who's
been out to defend him has debased
themselves and raised questions about
whether they're fit for office and you
know the few people who've had the
courage to speak up like to buy or sell
with the chair of the defense select
committee speaking truth to power today
heckled by his own side what has
happened to the modern conservative
party and is Boris Johnson that
charlatan really the best that the
conservative party has to offer the
country
okay where's treating thank you very
much indeed